the eurogroup conclure data site the nexe
you
mf will play a central role in the
economy
recovery stumme team of a chance then
gave f cause that europe and
marshall plan brought
we became massive f once to
primates in west each boy brave to
those workshops  that they experience
main buildings
is well your labor hurtful social
by that they in west each room is a breed
of
senior dazu so and strength of annona
european house out of the house it carries
he the there in that state of raw allah
mitch is state  transparent those rules in
miniature he had is out innovazione
engine
order had is out in west each
our instrument
labor is a beautiful graceful neck out
must back from investment
that the and feels to the dull fake bread
that european to god i feel  me
crisis are the sparrows and was in those
first years in amfi lists and i had
to mine would market
who dance groups ring and a fragment
here to that 6th mindshare market i  s [ __ ]
dan one and had to fill that slide
vidar stans kraft europe's stand